la segunda ciudad más grande de ucrania
sufre bombardeos casi a diario aparte de
las casas reducidas a escombros los
soldados de la defensa territorial han
registrado varias bajas mientras estaban
en medio del fuego de artillería
mientras el personal médico atiende a
los heridos otras tropas dirigen su
contraataque utilizando drones de alta
tecnología
[Música]
lo tengo es muy peligroso moverse ahora
hay un drone en el aire puedo solicitar
apoyo artillería
y
el norte de jarque ha sido el más
afectado
las tropas ucranianas aseguran que su
contraparte rusa ya lleva dos semanas de
constantes bombardeos en la ciudad no
hay gas agua ni electricidad y la falta
de alimentos complica el intento por el
retorno a la normalidad en medio de la
guerra y situarme y psib un hijo mío
está en el ejército si tuvieran
suficiente munición apart haríamos a
rusia hablo en nombre de todo el mundo
alejaremos a rusia porque somos
compatriotas y vivimos en nuestra tierra
este inmenso hueco en el suelo fue
causado por uno de los misiles rusos que
alcanzó una escuela de preparación
automovilística y aunque no se
registraron víctimas escombros y vidrios
rotos es lo único que queda de la
institución después de que el presidente
ruso vladimir putin se adjudicará la
victoria en la región de lugansk después
de la toma del issys sanz el nuevo
objetivo militar es la vecina región de
donges que ahí el panorama es muy
similar los bombardeos han causado
grandes columnas de humo el número de
heridos se empieza a aumentar y las
fuerzas ucranianas dudan abbas que
estamos ahora en el lugar del bombardeo
un edificio de varias plantas se ha
visto afectado así como casas
particulares los agentes de policía
están documentando las consecuencias del
crimen
el gobierno ucraniano mantiene la
esperanza de seguir recibiendo armas
adicionales de sus aliados para
neutralizar la enorme potencia de fuego
de rusia